ralphie what up yesterday you were
talking to richard he sat and [ __ ] on
the subway
right and that he didn't get changed and
he went to a bar and he hung out like
that all day
well the exact same thing happened to me
and you know what i did
i sat and [ __ ] i got right off the train
i
got some get to a hot dog car got some
napkins wiped it off went to a clothing
store
bought some clothes threw everything in
a bag and tossed it there is no [ __ ]
way richard is smarter than me i want a
rematch on this iq test
what was your iq ralph mine was 112 and
i believe
richards was 115. he shouldn't even be
close
i mean didn't he fall down and and he
broke his hand or something
but it's with my pinky on my left arm it
doesn't matter i don't use it a lot i
mean it's crazy
richard would you be willing to take
another uh
iq test to help ralph out here i refuse
to take another iq test the results
stand for themselves i am smart
it's funny too because i remember jason
being really bummed he's only a couple
points above me
i think i was hungover when i took it
and i know i can do better
i do believe you lost a few iq points
because you smoked too much weed
and i think you drink too much well then
richard
richard richard richard richard is
i guarantee if richard took it now he's
lower because
he's got to have a lower iq because he's
drinks so [ __ ] much you know i think
i've gotten smarter
i think working at this show makes you
smarter because we do
we use our brains all day so i think my
brain has gotten sharper yeah wouldn't
use your brain
for the richard watching south footy's
dick in his ass
i think he could have cured cancer but
this [ __ ] hillbilly
drank so much and he's so addicted to
alcohol that he's killed off so many
brain cells that he lost the cure for
cancer
right that's right we're all suffering
for it
no i i wasn't smart in junior high
either so i think you're wrong
i got an effort in that class i
i haven't had a drink in weeks i i i
rarely drink i'm ready yeah but you're
not growing new brain cells
oh yeah i am i'm working on that too
richard if richard's so smart how come
he doesn't go to the doctor for his hand
if her pinky is [ __ ] and
hurts and you didn't go to a doctor it's
doing better today
thank goodness here i'll show you
oh man oh god all right there's going to
be no rematch sorry to say thank you
richard come on you come on you know it
was a mistake
sorry you love when two low iq guys
fight over who has a higher iq